TRACE DOMINGUEZ: Hey, everyone.
Thanks for tuning
in to Seeker Plus.
I know this is also on Seeker.
This is a slightly
different format
where we get really deep into
a topic for a little while.
So stick with us.
I'm Trace.
This is going to be really cool.
We're talking about
artificial intelligence today.
And we didn't want to present
it as artificial intelligence is
scary or artificial
intelligence is the best,
but come down in the middle
and give you both perspectives
because there are people on both
sides of pretty much every one
of these debates.
So let's kick into it.
Artificial intelligence
is everywhere,
and it's growing both in
scope and also in scale.
It's just getting
to be in everything.
And people have strong
opinions on this.
One article called
"The Debate Itself--
Singulatarians Versus
Skeptics," which
we thought was kind of cool.
And people do see
artificial intelligence
as a possible threat--
people like Elon
Musk, Stephen Hawking,
Bill Gates kind of, and at
one point Steve Wozniak.
On the other side, people
see artificial intelligence
as the future and
inevitable-- people
like Larry Page of Google-- and
said that in order for Google
to achieve its mission,
that means achieving AI.
Mark Zuckerberg uses
AI to run his home,
and Facebook is moving
towards having AI assistants.
Even Uber has an AI division.
So it is like this old tech
new tech and with Elon Musk
right in the middle.
But chances are you all
probably know this stuff already
because you follow
Science News likely
if you're watching this show.
But one way to think about this
is positives and negatives.
Everyone has an opinion about
AI, and both of those opinions
are usually valid.
So we thought we'd see how
the debate is put together
rather than coming down
on one side or the other.
So let's quickly define
artificial intelligence.
It's not just robots and
chat bots and assistants.
It's being used across all
sorts of fields in industries,
and it's computers
and it's machines
imitating human intelligence.
But it's not just that.
It's more than just learning.
It's more than just
replicating our intelligence.
It's about learning new
things, and it's also
about the machines
learning on their own.
The big idea, the big
concept here could be great,
but it also could
be kind of scary.
So let's talk about
different ways
that you could apply
artificial intelligence.
A big one being
talked about right
now is artificially intelligent
automobiles, trucks,
and cars that drive themselves,
which, if you think about it,
that is an intelligent task.
It requires decision making
and learning and learning
from your experiences.
And a big thing would be safety.
90 percent of car
accidents now, car crashes,
are caused by
humans, human error.
Smart cars,
intelligent cars, they
would be able to take in
the environment around them.
GPS could tell them what
roads they're on and also
what buildings are nearby and
other monuments and things,
of course.
They have cameras and scanners.
So they can see the trees and
the way the road actually moves
versus what it's supposed to do.
And you can see things
like other cars.
Which what if they
were smart, too?
Then they could interact
with each other.
And then you have this network
that is moving everywhere.
What if you have
smart traffic lights?
Eventually this
whole system could
be one giant AI system
where they're all
talking to each other.
And then we could virtually
eliminate 90% of crashes,
right?
Assuming we're eliminating
all of the human error ones.
Of course, there are
moral issues here.
The car might be designed
to cause the least
damage to the owner of the car.
It might not want the car
to be destroyed in a crash.
And so that's a moral question.
Can the owner of the
car, say, a taxi company
decide not to protect
passengers or predestines
over protecting their property?
This is an ethical dilemma.
What about a guy who owns a car?
He would want to protect
his family at all costs.
But what if in doing
so it sacrificed
other people's
property or destroyed
other intelligent cars?
It gets complicated
because nothing
is black and white when you
get it out into the real world.
And that's part of the problem
with artificial intelligence
across the board right now--
is that the real world is messy.
Is it worth it to have a
self-driving intelligent car
that might not think some
humans are worth saving
over other humans or that some
property isn't worth saving
over other property even if
it can prevent more accidents,
even if it knows the fastest
routes and could drive itself,
so you wouldn't need to
worry about people under age
or people over age
or people who were
too intoxicated or inebriated
in any number of different ways?
At the end of the day,
intelligent automobiles
mean that, on the good side,
we don't have to go to the DMV.
We don't have to worry
about drunk driving.
But on the bad side, we're
taking our control away
from something that happens
all the time all around us
especially in urban areas.
So if you're in a car and
it's raining and you slide,
you go around a corner and
maybe something bad happens.
The road's too wet.
The car did something wrong.
It's either going
to destroy the life
of the person in the car or
a pedestrian on the sidewalk.
That decision is made by
a machine not by a human
and maybe by somebody
who programmed
or owned that machine.
We as a society have
to make a decision
to give up that control and
hand it to an artificially
intelligent machine.
How do you feel about that?
It's a debate.
There's good and
bad on both sides.
And this applies
across the board.
Let's go to another example--
marketing.
Marketing is
pervasive, especially
in the era of the internet.
Marketers want to know
where you're going to be,
what you're going to
buy, and what it takes
to get you to buy something.
You shop for shoes
that one time,
and now there's an ad for
shoes on every website you
visit and that shoe and a
couple of other different shoes
in a variety of true colors.
And they're all really nice, and
you kind of want all of them.
But you kind of
want none of them
because they're just everywhere.
Or maybe you regularly visit
a site on your computer
before you buy something.
Maybe you visit it 20 times.
Now right now all of that stuff
happens and all of that data
is there, but no
one's really looking
at all of that data
except artificially
intelligent machines.
Predictive shopping and
also recommendation engines
on Netflix and on Amazon--
those are basic
artificial intelligences.
So imagine if they
got way better.
When you shop for something,
do you just go and buy it
or do you visit the same
site once or twice, then
maybe look at some reviews, then
maybe ask your friends about it
and then go back and buy it?
An artificial
intelligence system
might be able to get you to
buy that sooner because they
know your behavior.
So when you go there
the first time,
what if an artificial
intelligent system
just pulled in recommendations
from the sites that you already
visit that it knows you visit
because of the cookies--
little files-- that
all of those sites
have stored on your computer?
What if it knew
your social network
and it went to your
friends who it knew
had bought from this
web site and already
bought these types
of items and said,
oh, here we know that all of
your friends like this thing
and we know where
you've shopped before.
And the artificially
intelligent system
could anticipate what you want.
Is that scary or is that good?
Because sometimes I
kind of like shoes,
but I don't know what I want.
And maybe the computer can
tell me you do want this,
and I might love it.
But also it's kind of creepy
to know that the computer knows
my shopping habits and knows
what websites I've visited
and knows what my friends
like and is anticipating
what I might like.
Good but also bad.
The Trump campaign tapped
into a marketing AI
to help determine how it wanted
to send out its messaging.
And this marketing AI claims
to have 45,000 data points
on 230 million Americans.
They claim that they know
what makes us angry, happy,
impassioned, or despondent.
That's a lot of
power for somebody
to have and be able
to then manipulate
all sorts of different
people into doing
what they want because that's
what marketing is about--
is I want to market
something to you.
I have to know how
to reach you in order
to do that and push your buttons
and all sorts of other things.
The idea is to get you to make
an emotional decision rather
than a rational one
from time to time.
Again, good or bad?
What do you think?
How about in medicine?
Medicine is a field with
huge amounts of data.
But most of that data
is protected and stored
in very specific places,
sometimes never even digitally.
It's just papers or it's just
file names and not so much
all of the stuff in the file.
AI machines could
potentially take
in huge amounts of this
data, like medical records,
doctor's notes, treatment
options, disease histories,
family histories,
genetic information,
and find patterns that
could help doctors diagnose
diseases in people that
they didn't even know
would have them.
Let me give you an example.
If I can analyze, as an
intelligent machine, all
of your medical history and
also all of everyone else's
medical history, who has all
of these genetic markers, what
if I can find a pattern and
then use that to diagnose you
and many other people?
Would that offset
the fact that I now
have your medical
information and I'm using it?
Yeah, sure.
I'm using it to
help other people.
Great.
But I also have your
private medical data.
Maybe not great.
The AI system
doesn't necessarily
care whether it has all of your
data, but the more data it has,
the better it's going
to be able to do.
It does involve
us giving up some
of this control to an
intelligent machine
in order to get a benefit back.
On top of that, is
it good to take away
humans from healthcare?
Will we rely someday 100%
on computers diagnosing us?
They don't really have emotions.
They don't have gut feelings.
They can't read real patients'
experience in the same way
that a well-trained doctor can.
However, computers can
examine data and find patterns
in our genetic codes and things.
Lists of symptoms really
help with computers,
but doctors don't always
get the whole list.
I've watched a lot of "House."
I know there's a lot of lying
that goes on in the examination
room.
I have lied to my doctor.
I imagine you have, too.
How often do you drink a week?
Oh, a couple of times.
Is it a couple of
times or is it more?
Mm?
However, how many times
have you googled something
that you don't want
to tell anybody about?
Probably lots of times.
So maybe, in this case,
again, good and bad.
Real people have all
of these gut feelings
and can help you
understand what's going on,
but you'll tell
machines something
that you may not tell people.
So an artificially
intelligent doctor
might be able to help
you in that way in a way
that a person can't
and vice versa.
Really interesting discussion.
We don't have the answer.
Maybe you do.
Let us know.
So moving on.
What about jobs?
And specifically certain jobs.
An Oxford study that
came out in 2013
looked at 700 different jobs
and assessed their ability
to be automated and their
probability that they would be.
The jobs at the top of the
list, which is actually
the bottom of the
list, were things
like legal advising, marketing,
bank teller, tax prep, shipping
and cargo control, in
fact, most everything
you can think of for retail
and auditing and tax adjusting,
even sports--
things like umpires and refs.
They were the number 15
most automatable job.
Why do I need a referee if I
have an intelligent system that
can do this job?
It's just assessing the rules
and debating whether or not
somebody had broken them.
That is easy to
do for a computer.
It's not as easy to do with
a referee or an umpire.
Sports journalism,
even, has already
been done in large part
much of it by robots.
Humans are just
slower at this stuff.
And calculating is
what computers do.
So isn't this some place
where artificial intelligence
is going to come in?
Now many of you are
probably already thinking
about how computers and
robots have taken some jobs.
And the first things that
pop into people's heads are--
at least people like
myself from Michigan--
is the auto industry.
It's already taken a lot
of jobs there-- automation.
It's not people building cars.
It's people managing
robots building cars.
This has also happened
in cargo ships
and in shipping in general.
In fact, "99% Invisible"
and Alex Madrigal
came out with this really
great audio documentary
called "Containers."
It was featured on
"99% Invisible."
It was really good.
So go check it out.
And it talks all
about how docks used
to be this really exciting place
filled with people and smells
and sights.
And now it's more automated.
And one person with a
crane moves containers
from one place to another.
It's very different.
All of that is
automation taking over.
Now imagine why do we need
the person operating the crane
if we have an artificial
intelligence that can do that
and it can do it faster
and more precisely?
Interesting.
What about automation in
a variety of other things
like when you buy coffee?
Do I really need to
buy it from a person
if I have an artificially
intelligent system that
can bring me that coffee?
Sidebar-- the vending
machine, where
you get snacks or whatever.
That's technically an
artificial intelligence system.
It knows how much
money you put in.
It knows what you want.
And then you walk away.
The first vending machines
showed up in 1070 in China.
They were coin operated
pencil vending machines.
In the 1970s, there were
machines that dispensed tobacco
at taverns.
And by the late 1800s, you
could get paper, envelopes,
postcards, gum, and
things on train platforms
and at post offices.
And that was somebody's
livelihood before.
That was somebody who
was selling you envelopes
and gum or tobacco or pencils.
So robots and automation
have been taking jobs
for a long time-- end sidebar.
Anyway, back to
this Oxford study
because it's super interesting.
Humans are slower
at calculating,
like we were saying.
But if you take tax prep jobs,
bank teller jobs, retail jobs
and you give them to
intelligent machines,
we are again giving up
control, giving up access
to something that used
to be done by humans
and was also a point of
contact of me with a stranger
or you with a friend.
We're giving that to a machine,
which some people come down
on the good side of--
I don't want to have to interact
with somebody to get coffee.
I just want coffee--
and some people come
down on the bad side of--
I would rather have my
person than my coffee.
It's part of my morning ritual.
It's part of how I
go through my day.
And if you take
that away from me,
then that's one less person
that I get to interact with,
and that makes me happy.
Artificial intelligence can
do so many different things,
and it will do so many
different things in the future.
But for now, it's all
a matter of debate.
On top of that, again,
another sidebar.
If you take away retail and all
of these low level entry level
jobs, what replaces them?
What happens then?
How does someone in
high school or college
get into the workforce
or pay for college?
How do they earn money if
an artificial intelligence
is already doing that job?
How do you get started at work
if all of the entry level jobs
are done by machines?
An interesting question.
There's no real answer
to that at the moment.
What about an education?
Right now the education
system is in peril.
We need more money for schools.
We need less money for schools.
It depends on who
you ask, and it
depends on what outlook you have
on the future of our education
system.
But an obvious downfall
of artificial intelligence
moving into education
is taking the roles
of teachers, where
an obvious upside is
that an artificial intelligence
will be able to do the best
job at teaching in terms of
knowing what you need to learn
and knowing how to present
that information to you,
so that you learn at the best.
When people say that they're--
I'm a visual learner,
I'm a reading learner,
or I'm an audio learner--
an artificially
intelligent machine
can do all of those
things equally well,
whereas a teacher
might be better
at some rather than others.
It's a debate.
And, again, we're relinquishing
this control over something
that we have traditionally
had control over in order
to potentially have an upside.
But that upside might
also have a downside.
Even assisting the teacher
would be really interesting
because the AI maybe do tutor
stuff with individual students
on an individual basis very
personalized for what they
need, while the teacher is
there to give them social skills
and interaction and make sure
that the classroom as a whole
is progressing together.
They can work together.
This debate does often
feel black and white,
but perhaps it's
less so because,
if everyone is learning
from a computer
but they're getting
their social skills
from other humans, what does
that mean for how we think?
Are we going to have
trouble thinking
when interacting with humans?
| posing more questions than
I'm answering in this episode,
but I think the exciting thing
is that artificial intelligence
holds so much promise in so many
different areas of our culture
and our experience
and our abilities
to do more in the future
that, when people say,
I'm afraid of the
robot takeover,
they're obviously only
looking at this bad column
and not at this good column.
Because we could learn
quicker and better and more
personalized.
We could have more
personalized medicine.
We could have better automobiles
and automobile safety.
But we'd also not
control those cars.
We'd not control our
healthcare data as easily.
We wouldn't have as
much social interaction.
We bought coffee maybe.
There are things
you have to give up.
But we've given
up things before.
And we're OK now.
There are lots of
other applications
that we don't have time to get
into, like in the entertainment
industry, in the
security industry,
in systems that make music or
make movies or write stories.
AI can be good, but, like
everything, maybe it's
AI in moderation.
If every aspect of
our lives is being
driven by intelligent
machines, does that
take away our ability to
be intelligent ourselves?
I don't know.
Think about it.
A lot of what humans
have been doing
over the last few millennia
is just figuring out
how to live our
lives on this planet
and how to make the best of the
situation that we are all in.
We're in a giant aquarium
floating in space,
and we're all trying to figure
out the best way to live inside
of this bubble.
AI can help us with
that potentially,
but it will change things.
So where do you
come down on that?
If AI can do all these
things that we used to have
to do, then what do we do?
All right, guys.
Thanks so much for
watching this episode
about artificial intelligence.
Let us know what you think
down in the comments.
Make sure that you watch last
week's episode on InfraRed
right here.
And one more favor to ask.
Please go over to
vote.webbyawards.com
because we got nominated for
a Webby in the people's choice
category, and we need your vote.
It's for the Edge
of Space video we
did where we sent a camera
into the stratosphere.
It's so cool if you
haven't watched it.
Go watch it.